Speaker 1: Oh, Sam still has to put her stuff up. Oh, yeah. We ought to know you're tenacious. Everybody in your team here is just about tenacious. What is it? What was it? What was it, Josh? Did you guys try to do it? They don't think anybody did proper work. Oh, wow. It was just a pattern practice. Yeah. Because we needed to get things done. I remember Josh asking us, like, are you tenacious when he's talking about the concept. And I was like, yeah.
Speaker 1: But I was like, I might have realized I was saying, yeah, I'm intense. And he was not, by definition, tenacious. To get to know you better. Oh. Maybe I need to take a look. Oh, yeah. Yeah. You have to share with us either an aha moment or anything related to categorizing you so we know everything about you, by the way. Okay.
Speaker 2: If they don't trickle over your room. Dang that. Great.
Speaker 3: Wait, how personality is great? Or, like, what in nature? I said in the beginning. Like, how does it mean anything to anyone that doesn't know me? They all know. Oh, you do? All right. Well, I'm in Enneagram 1, Wing 9.
Speaker 1: Wait. Does that mean there's three of you here.
Speaker 4: So, me and Sam are almost identical people. We are so weird. Like, when I met Nikki... I was going to say that. We actually have a section. It was, like, uncomfortable.
Speaker 3: It was, like, we are... We do a lot.
Speaker 4: I mean, there's a lot going on, and it's the same.
Speaker 3: We're just, like, so similar. Can I say this? Yeah. So, TE, Static Enablement, Enneagram 1, Wing 9, which... God bless my nine. My aha moment, I think, was that, like, pit in my stomach I feel when I walk into a meeting and someone starts by saying, like, I'm going to daydream. This whole meeting, we're going to dream. And I'm, like, oh, kill me not. Yeah. Waste of time to dream and, like, not do anything. So, the aha moment was, like, oh, I'm just not wired to be a big dreamer.
Speaker 3: So, that was it.
Speaker 4: It gave me a lot of freedom to appreciate what I am good at. yeah and give it a name yeah like that for me was a big thing and where I fit in with a good team you know and knowing that if I miss out it's not all my fault because I'm not wired to be inventive I just hate whiteboards when I see one that I'm like just to start off from nothing it's like I can't grasp on I.
Speaker 4: can't get high enough in my thoughts to see that yeah hundred thousand foot view yeah I have to latch on to something give me a cloud I mean anything.
Speaker 1: in my house and two regular whiteboard whiteboards like one in my office and a black one in my office another one in another room one in my kitchen, yeah I'm gonna write down this or my kids have a question about, I'm going to do it on a whiteboard. My wife says, this is what kids would complain about. She's like, this is what we're talking about at dinner. I've got a strategy. I've discerned and invented a problem.
Speaker 1: No, no, no. What? It's not very one-ish. Like, have you list? Like, I thought, OK, I do. No, no, no list. Oh, no list. Zero list. My wife uses the list, and I erase the list. Oh! Zero list. I want a clean board at all times. I wish somebody would just go behind me and erase it all so that I can come back and do it again. I have a new idea.
Speaker 4: Is your middle name like Patrick Lencioni.
Speaker 1: I had never heard of him until Josh had mentioned when I was interviewing him.
Speaker 4: So you hadn't read like the five discussions of the team.
Speaker 1: I haven't read any of them. Really? Until, like I said, I was interviewing Josh. And before I did the interviews with the rest of the team, well, the rest with the subset of the team, He had said that everybody first reads the leadership one. Leadership and subsection, I thought, I should probably read what you guys read. So I kind of had an idea of what it's like to be on board the block. And then I thought, oh, this is awesome. So I actually picked up two or three of these other things and read them, because I like the allegories.
Speaker 1: They're things I felt like I could share with non-corporate professional people and still connect with the ideas on it, so that was really fun. Cool. OK, thank you for participating. Sam. Really cool. That's all right. How many hours did I make it? One and a half. It's a new record. Yeah, you guys are friends.
Speaker 1: So the rest of today is going to be about outlining these workflows with incredible precision. decision, and we want to start, we made some assumptions. We believe that there are five primary workflows that you guys. execute within these two systems. And we may or may not be right. So don't think, just, and these workflows, within them, there are tinier workflows, right?
Speaker 1: So these are what I would call the big picture workflows. So before we actually show you what our five workflows are, we work through one, and the first one will probably be the slowest, and then we'll get to what we get. Nick, I guess I wanted to give us, take maybe, do you want to turn that clock to 15 minutes? I'm thinking of 15 minutes, I have no idea.
Steve Muniak: Oh, wait, sorry, can you interrupt me? Yeah, no, keep going. When we take a break later, we'll do it.
Speaker 1: No, let's do two, three, four, and then I will. We'll probably get to something about two, so I don't mind. If you want to wait, I'm just saying. I got to pick up a good line. Oh, I'm not going to lie. That's his lie right there. You guys don't know. I did not try to, I was just trying to, I never liked it. No? No. Okay. Who wants to go first? Me? I'm not ready. I thought you were saying you had a great life. No, I don't think you have a good life.
Speaker 4: You're inventive. I mean, like, you can invent a lot.
Jake Herwaldt: I can actually go first. But I'm also a pastor, so I've learned each day. I wrote mine down, because I had to think about it. And I know if I'm like, what is my life? All right, so, all of them, we were talking about broken bones. I almost shared stories, and I was like, hold on. So, all of mine are around broken bones. So, I broke my arm falling out of a ride at Cedar Point, middle school. When I was 18 months old, I broke my leg, and my parents didn't realize it was broke for a couple days.
Jake Herwaldt: In high school, I broke my leg on a beach on Christmas Day. That's very deep. They're all pretty deep.
Speaker 3: The middle one wasn't. Was it the same leg you broke when you were a baby.
Jake Herwaldt: Oh, that's a good question. It was to the left. Actually, it was the same leg. It was. But I broke my other leg, too, as well. I've broken a lot of bones.
Speaker 3: Really.
Jake Herwaldt: Yeah, actually.
Speaker 3: More than just your leg.
Jake Herwaldt: My, yeah, my legs and my arms. Yeah. That surprised me. Well, that's a good one. I found out at night school I had a bone problem. But we're good now. We're good now. Makes sense.
Speaker 1: Are we supposed to write the answers down? How does this work? I don't know.
Jake Herwaldt: Somebody call me up.
Speaker 1: Somebody has to do a bold assertion. And if they're wrong, they have one in the plank. And if they're right, the other person has a... That's the way we do things. You did not break your arm into your form.
Steve Muniak: That's my bold assertion.
Speaker 4: I'm going to say the Christmas Day one. You're going to a beach on Christmas Day.
Speaker 1: I've done it. Oh yeah. You think he's got a truth there, but he adjusted it for the lie.
Jake Herwaldt: Yeah, that's wild. It's like 90% truth. Well, it wasn't on Christmas Day. I can just reveal. Am I really? I think Cedar Point went live. I am Cedar Point, probably.
Speaker 2: You were traveling to the beach somewhere. That had happened. How did your parents not know that you broke.
Jake Herwaldt: I was 18 months. They just thought I wasn't crawling. But I was walking at the time. I don't know. I kind of slid into it. Walking? It happened. I mean, I was walking. It happened to one of my kids, too. Wow. They were just like, we just thought you were tired for two days. How did you break it? Do you know? I was kicking a soccer ball down a hill. My brother was playing soccer. down a hill and apparently my dad doesn't know he was watching me he I was at the bottom of the hill. How many siblings and what was your name? I'm one of four, I'm the third.
Speaker 4: There you go, little children. We get forgotten about. Figure it out yourself.
Speaker 1: Usually they say it takes like the first one's pretty good and then the 12th one's good.
Steve Muniak: I'm number two in the list, I don't know what that means. I'll go next. I'm a German citizen, I cater on the side as a side hustle and I have a sports pilot license.
Speaker 1: Do you have a what? A sports pilot license. That sounds real to me because it's very specific and unfiltered, but it could be a weird one. I don't think you cater on the side. I mean if you did, I would be in touch.
Speaker 2: I just said cater on the side. I just fed 50 people yesterday.
Steve Muniak: Oh! I did all my kids' rehearsal dinners, all that. I am a German citizen, I have dual citizenship as of 2020, up until then German citizenship was passed down only on the paternal side, we made a decision to allow for maternal citizenships and my son led the charge, we all have, we're all German citizens, and I do not have a sports.
Steve Muniak: license. What does that mean, by the way? What's that? What does that mean? Sports is a much lower license than a typical, but if you wanted to do ultralights and things like that, it's something I've thought about. I saw somebody cruising on that.
Speaker 1: Oh yeah, the pair of poles. Right over our house the other day, I didn't think it was you. There was who can come at you. Yeah, there was Randy Peters. I've thought about it. Alright, I have my light. Hang on, I'm really not good at this one, you guys. I've been in two more political actions in my life. I have a pretty bad peanut allergy. And what's the lie? No.
Speaker 1: I have a... If I could go to the moon in my life, I might would.
Speaker 3: Okay, very good. I'll just go to the moon. I just need my wife to sign up on this and I do not have that. Yeah. I mean, I have a kidney to be a word then.
Steve Muniak: Peanut allergy. Yeah, that's a good thing. Let me just find out right now. I also didn't really expect that.
Speaker 1: No label. I don't look at it.
Jake Herwaldt: I'm so glad I don't look at allergies right now. Fortunately, more political actions weren't like that, but they were unpleasant.
Speaker 3: And that was before you had kids.
Speaker 1: That was before I had kids, yeah, yeah. Because that would have been, yeah, a lot of things would be... Oh, yeah. And that's right, we talked about Cedar Point, because you kind of knew that was a lot, because I did that for my first accident. Like, Cedar Point was a ton of fun, and then you have an accident, and all of a sudden it's a scary event. The idea that some of the changes in your body, you're like, we're doing it again. Get on with your ride.
Speaker 2: I have to think of stuff that, like, Sam and Vicki and...
Speaker 3: I know! Oh, I know! That's how I work with these guys. Yeah, that's true. Pretty wild. Okay, I have a dumb one. I've been skydiving, Rocky Mountain climbing, and I went 2.7 seconds on a bulldozer. I've never heard that before. That sounds like a great idea. Yeah! Which one of those is not true? Say that. I'm not guessing. No? I have a feeling I know.
Speaker 3: The song. Mm-hmm. I went skydiving, I went... Rocky Mountain Climbing, and I went 2.7 seconds on a bull named Fu Manchu.
Speaker 1: I mean, that's a very specific third one, so I would be really impressed if you did that.
Speaker 3: Unless you named the bull after you did it. How do you get skydiving since you've lived on a picture of your ranch dream? It doesn't have a deuterium, so that helps.
Speaker 7: Oh, that's good to know, because that does help. And you would name the bull.
Speaker 4: That's so tricky, isn't it.
Steve Muniak: Is it a real bull.
Speaker 4: Yeah. It's impressive. She did live in Colorado.
Steve Muniak: I know. So I really did live that first one. Skydiving.
Speaker 3: I have been skydiving and Rocky Mountain Climbing, and I have heard a real bull. But it's not. But its name was not Fu Manchu. And it was way more than 2.7 seconds for me. I wrote it like a horror film. I was like, all right. I was like, why is it tough? I know. It's a very old text of all. It was not fucking. It's so funny. I'll freak out. Of course.
Speaker 4: Yeah, I'm trying to come up with the truth that would have to, like, get us.
Speaker 3: We cannot, like, guess.
Speaker 4: Yeah.
Speaker 3: Because you can give one. We just know a lot of them. Right. They would love that.
Speaker 4: Two lies and a truth? Give you guys better chances.
Speaker 3: You didn't know it was going to be so hard. Yeah.
Speaker 4: Because it's coming up with nothing. Like, starting with nothing.
Speaker 7: That would make a problem.
Speaker 1: Could you all just give us a sign or something, Steve? What's that? Couldn't you have just given us an assignment? I know. Paperwork. Somebody might have got that.
Speaker 3: I actually don't, but I feel like mostly women. I married my high school sweetheart. I was supposed to be, like, my career dream originally was to be a nurse.
Speaker 2: and I have camped at all of the Michigan State Units.
Speaker 8: That reference is great.
Speaker 7: You can just put it in there and just throw it in there. Sure. That's ambiguous enough, but I don't want to do it. Can't tell you.
Speaker 1: I'm just going to be a nurse. Well, you remember that if you were calling me a lie.
Speaker 2: I play the game that night. All of us? I'm going to say the third one. I don't think we know. Yeah, third. I think we've done, we did almost third. Wow. That's a lot. It was our goal for a while. How many are there? A lot.
Speaker 3: Oh, boy. The ones that we could, that I counted that we could bring our family time. That's awesome.
Steve Muniak: Nurse.
Speaker 3: No, it was the state parks.
Steve Muniak: Oh, it was the state parks? Yes. Oh, sorry.
Speaker 3: I was supposed to be a nurse. I had appendicitis my last May, my senior year. And I had this vivid moment that I was in the hospital and the nurses were so nice. And I was like, I'm not this nice. And I had to change everything. And then I went and got a finance degree instead.
Speaker 4: Wow.
Speaker 2: If you're using it.
Speaker 4: Yeah. That's it.
Speaker 2: Okay, I feel like black people aren't allowed to answer this. I know. That's what I'm having trouble with. I can't get a story that you guys are not. So I guess the people that I work with. Yes. Okay. Let's see. I worked at Hot Topic in the mall when I was in high school. I have a 21-year-old daughter, and I have 10 tattoos.
Speaker 8: Hot Topic. That's going to sound like Hot Topic. Yeah, I was just thinking that. I was just thinking that you said it. What do you do at Hot Topic.
Speaker 2: What I do at Hot Topic? Yeah. I sell clothes, fold all the time. Was it because of you being my emo, because I'm a huge Nirvana fan? So, you know, being my whole Kurt Cobain era of life. My angst. I just love my Junko jeans and big t-shirts.
Speaker 7: And this is very legal, yeah. I've worked at Hot Topic.
Speaker 3: Of course I worked at Hot Topic. My mother would have never. I know. My nephew had to dress up for soccer, and he gets to the school, and she works at the school. And he was wearing his dad's pants, because it was all good and fine, and I was like, do they look like dick cookies? We're awake. Then you have to look it up.
Speaker 7: I'm like, what does that mean.
Speaker 1: Andy, you're a tattooist. What do you think she does? I think she has some more. What do you think she has? I'm going to say it's a tattoo thing, because it's... Well, I have. They're all pretty good.
Speaker 1: So we're all like, yeah, she's like, oh, they're going to totally think I'm going to get a hot dog. Actually, we're like, no, she's got more tips.
Speaker 2: I've got more tips. No, I have 10, so, yeah. And then along with the 21-year-old daughter, I have a nine and almost seven-year-old stepson. That's a good one.
Speaker 1: Okay. I can go next if somebody wants me. So you can see that people aren't ready. I'm like, good, good, okay. All right, I'm trying to keep these thematic. But the longest I've run is 50 miles. The fastest I've completed a marathon is three hours and 45 minutes. And the longest I've been awake is 60 hours. Oh, wow.
Speaker 4: I was going to say, I don't know, maybe the, would you say 50 hours? 50 miles? 50 miles.
Speaker 1: The furthest I've run is 50 miles. The longest I've been away is 60 hours. The fastest marathon is 3 hours and 45 minutes. I really hope it's the awakening.
Speaker 4: I don't think it is. Yeah, I think that's the truth. I think you start to go crazy.
Jake Herwaldt: Oh, I think he would push that barrier down. I think he'd like to go crazy. Yeah, someone would be like, you can't do four days. It's 10 days. Five days. How many days is that.
Speaker 4: Your brain starts shutting down after three days. Ooh, it's the science. Literally going to insanity.
Jake Herwaldt: He's like, I've been riding a half steam this whole time. Every penny sticks. We're drunk at all.
Speaker 1: No. We're just. We're drunk at all. No drugs were involved in any of these unless you consider caffeine. All right. I think it's number two. What was number two? Oh, marathon runs. I'm going to go one. Is that the 50 miles? 50 miles. 50 miles.
Speaker 4: Same.
Speaker 1: Yeah. The answer is my fastest marathon is 3 hours and 40 minutes. I technically never signed up for a marathon. I've only done longer races, and so my fastest marathon is like 6 hours on the road to 50 hours. But I have stayed up to 60 hours. Was that for the race? No. It was for fun.
Speaker 1: Oh, man. 50 miles. It was an event I did in 2019, it was a 50 plus, 52 hours of it was this event put on by ex-Navy SEALs and current Navy SEALs, and then I was up before it, and I stayed up after I finished it. And I remember thinking after I got done, I was like, I'm going to get 60 hours. I don't remember the last hour, so they had to put me to bed to get me.
Speaker 1: Because there were some guys who took care of us after we were done.
Speaker 3: Is that the author, the Navy SEAL guy that wrote... Jocko. No, no. Never finished. There's a book, never finished. The one that drops off songs all the time. It's a great book, though.
Speaker 1: Are you talking about Goggins.
Speaker 3: Yes, David Goggins.
Speaker 1: Yes, I listened to Can't Hurt Me.
Speaker 3: Okay.
Speaker 1: While I was training for it. Yeah.
Speaker 3: That book made me want to wake up with badass.
Speaker 1: Yeah. It was sort of a... I turned 30, and I was trying to look at what would make... I looked at 40-year-olds, and I was not... I was trying to look at a pattern of what 40-year-olds were enjoying their life, and what 40-year-olds were sort of like was happening to them. And I decided my best life wasn't going to be the path of Jesus' choices, and I had to, on how to make uncomfortable choices before our time.
Speaker 1: It just so happened that I wanted to make 60 hours because I wanted to make 60 hours. Your brain is different. But you'd be surprised at the power of sunlight. Once you get the first, like your brain at 3 AM is very groggy, messed up. But sunlight triggers your cycle to be like, oh, it's time to get up. So you can kind of get through. And even the second night we went through,
Speaker 1: my brain roughly 40 hours versus 48, and the sunlight hit again. Oh, yeah, I can be awake now. All right, I'm ready.
Speaker 4: I have been to two other continents. I'm an avid skateboarder, and I've ran, Two tough ones.
Speaker 8: What counties.
Speaker 4: Can I tell that.
Speaker 1: Sure. Are these your counties? I'm reading your micro-expressions.
Speaker 4: Africa and Australia. What kind of skateboard do you like? The long flat boarder. The long boarder. It might be that one.
Speaker 2: I don't know. Or she wants to think that.
Speaker 3: You won't know if I tell you. The real long one. There is difference. I don't know.
Speaker 4: absolutely hate but jumping off the 30 foot ledge is the most fun because it's also the most.
Speaker 1: frightening she's definitely done some of those hominins oh no that's funny okay good i agree that yeah i think that's probably that's like 11 anybody who says they like to drive is probably like it's not the cold and i did both of them in the rain in like 40 degree weather it's stupid thing they still hold this yeah it's just the long board of the skate i'm gonna go.
Speaker 2: i was gonna think that that's you yeah get in my head it's like you should tell them what you aren't instead of skateboarding though vicky what actually do you do the um the.
Speaker 4: The reason for going to other continents was for rifle shooting. I used to be on the United States Rifle Shooting Team. Whoa. I was on a vice captain. How far away can you hit me at a run? Do you want to find out? So competition-wise, per competition, it was 800 to 1,000 yards. That is a long way. And we had no scopes. It was just .
Speaker 1: Iron sights. That's crazy. How big of a target are you hitting at.
Speaker 4: So it was, I think the whole target was 12 by 12. That's long. So feet.
Speaker 7: Feet, OK.
Jake Herwaldt: I would have figured.
Speaker 4: Because you can hold out your arms, and you wouldn't be able to touch the 308 rifle.
Speaker 1: I grew up in, like, my grandpa was in the military, so I've read a lot of military things. So when I used to walk in from the big parking lot, I knew the snipers could hit me from the parking lot. I was, like, pacing it out, like, that's not even hard for them. No. That's bad. It's a long ways.
Steve Muniak: Anybody ever been to the D. Lee book? No. In Dallas? Oh, no. It's a, it's, it was shooting the, wow, literally, you just, you see it, you walk, you get up to that window, you look down, it says, oh, yeah, he hit him.
Speaker 3: See, do you remember, this is random, we were at Kid Rock Bar in Nashville. It was a bunch of people from the industry. Which time I met you. Was that the first time? Yeah. And there were snipers at the building across the street, and so from the bar, it just had open walls. You could look, and you could see the buildings across the street, and there were men dressed in full tactical gear, all black, with rifles. And, like, downtown Nashville's insane, right? So it's people everywhere partying, and you're just, like, sitting there. And I was so nervous, because I'm, like, from the country, so I'm, like, oh, my God. What happened to me? Protecting the people. No way.
Speaker 3: I'm really surprised. I think. There had been, like, some shootings, and I think they were literally there to respond. Be a presence. Yeah. Which was a good thing. On one level, I'm like, but it was just unsettling. Everyone's having a time and dancing, and I'm just like, oh, my God. Well, that was on the road. That's great.
Speaker 1: Jordan? Am I the last one? Yes. All right. I had to type mine out, too, because it took me forever to figure it out. I gave up on, like, block people knowing, because it's hard. I grew up on a blueberry farm. My first job in high school was at a library, and I was a drummer in a band in high school. It's all very believable. Can you do a little rhythm for me? A little rhythm for you? I like how he's taking it. What was it?
Speaker 1: I played drums, and I gave up. What kind of band was it? It was a, like, punk rock band, alternative. Okay. Can you give us a swing?
Speaker 1: I was making that up. I don't remember anything. I think you were a blueberry guy, so I don't get a line about that. What was the number two one again? What was the one you sandwiched in the middle? My first job in high school was at a library. I was talking about your second job. How egregious should the lie be, right? I do kind of feel like you were in a punk band. I think. Not because of what you did, that was not the answer.
Speaker 1: Nobody would have mentioned that. I don't know. I wasn't a punk fan, but I played guitar in a punk band. That's what I thought. You played guitar. You were sneaky. Yeah. Sneaky. Only a small lie there. Too funny. The funny thing, too, is I worked at the library that was like two houses down from Vicky's grandparents' house. Oh, my gosh. And I didn't meet Vicky until I went to church with Vicky's grandparents and never met Vicky until I went to block.
Speaker 3: I worked with Vicky's grandpa.
Speaker 1: Did you really.
Speaker 3: Yeah. I loved him. He was like an art. Riffle art. He was like my favorite person that I knew. He was so good.
Speaker 1: Where were you working at.
Speaker 3: At the Mac.
Speaker 1: Okay. Yeah.
Speaker 3: That's awesome. Yeah, the connections are weird.
Speaker 4: My grandpa loved the city and like the community and he knew everybody. What was that place in Mason that was like the older folks' home? It's right down Jefferson. Welcome.
Steve Muniak: So, Steve, did you acquire enough information to use this against us on the beach? I didn't know anybody, just a little bit better. Where some of the weaknesses are.
Speaker 1: We're bad at lying. If that's a weakness. I mean, I play clarinet.
Speaker 3: I play the viola. I'm out. You can do the triangle. I can play half cross buzz on the recorder. I just practiced it the other day. My daughter was on her recorder and I was like, I bet you I can still fuck that half cross buzz. Did you have the practice.
Speaker 8: Alright.
Speaker 1: Okay. I still have a second lunch to finish, but I'll get there. What you'll see on the board, the wall, is in fact, the world's greatest post-it note of workflows. Well, the goal of that, do you think so? No, no. This isn't the whole workflow. This is just the first five.
Speaker 4: Do we name the workflow or all of the steps in the process.
Speaker 1: No, no, no, just the name. So my goal is that we, I think that reasonably fit seven workflows if we write legibly. Oh, and if we keep them in post-it. No, we don't even need to keep them. I don't mind actually writing them not post-it. Okay. Because, and if you guys have, like, I think that can fit. I'll even put on there, I'll write the numbers on there so we stay within. I don't mind if there are eight. I just know we have said, we believe that there are five, and we might be right, we might be wrong.
Speaker 1: I just want to hear from your perspective what those are. So we'll just say for sure there's two, three, four, five, six. Look at that. You got spacing. Do you go beyond seven? If you go beyond seven, you can just write on that. It's an extension of the world's greatest business.
Jake Herwaldt: Andy, can you give us an example of a workflow so that we can hone this out? Oh, yeah. Can you give me an example? External buyer. An external buyer workflow. OK, yeah. External. Just a little example, that way we know.
Speaker 1: So you want this high level. Yes. We are going to next. Yes. OK. So the external buyer process could be 20, 30 mini workflows, or 10, which this is where you're going to think people.
Jake Herwaldt: You can think teams. You can think, and you might want.
Speaker 1: to say the external buyer purchasing thing. Part. Anybody who wants to. You guys don't, but I would. Oh, if you have good handwriting, or are we going to.
Speaker 3: I get good handwriting. OK. And I can write it. It's probably not even like yours. I love tangents.
Speaker 1: It's going to go a while. Just tell us what it is, because we're going to try to compare it to here. And we're trying to, because if we're right about our five, then we're not trying to make more. We're just going to not give you our five.
Speaker 3: OK. Well, I would follow that up with internal buyer.
Jake Herwaldt: Look at that. Internalized.
Speaker 4: Well, there's two different, three different kinds of internal buyers. But that's what you're saying, like, we do later.
Steve Muniak: Well, that's what's, hopefully, the light to the park captured some of the, yeah, team complexity for that.
Speaker 3: Yeah. Do you like our . It's beautiful. It's a lot, because I'll look at that more, errors, but it's good. I'm just here, so we're good. Yeah, externals under internals.
Jake Herwaldt: Are they right? Ding, ding, ding.
Speaker 4: Did your wife pick out that Tupperware size? That's why it's working. I do it with my kids.
Speaker 3: Would this be like the vendor data management.
Jake Herwaldt: I don't know fully what those words mean, but write it up. Let's do it.
Speaker 4: So what kind of workflows are we? Are we talking about like sourcing window reaching workflows.
Jake Herwaldt: Yes. Sorry. Good. Yeah. Good.
Speaker 4: These are users. Are we... Yeah. We're talking about user groups. ... too high for workflow.
Speaker 1: I think so. I think we... I realize that... These are experiences. Yeah. The external buyer... I'm assuming what we meant by that is the external buyer purchasing a part of sourcing, window pro. Yeah. The internal buyer... purchasing a part of it there. So maybe if we, we don't have a verb there. We probably need to add external buyer for purchasing.
Speaker 3: Can you put S-O-V-P next to external buyer? So that doesn't make only one internal buyer. This persona has multiple . Yes, they all have multiple workflows.
Jake Herwaldt: And that's fine, that's fine. This is actually more focused on the user than the workflow. We're going to do workflows for the users. Yes, sorry. So this is identifying essentially the users. All in the pockets of people.
Speaker 1: Okay.
Jake Herwaldt: So you have external buyer, great. We will then branch off to see all the 20,000 things.
Speaker 1: Why did I use the word workflows then.
Jake Herwaldt: I don't know, that's fine. Do you want to go more? We will then, we are going to the next step is to then create the workflow. Can you call it personas? You can correct that, yeah.
Speaker 3: Okay, that makes sense.
Jake Herwaldt: Personas. Could you write it a little taller.
Speaker 1: That's a good point though, we can use our personas, and see if you said actors, because that's the language you guys use.
Steve Muniak: It's just another form, it doesn't matter. I'm asking because personas is a little bit easier to use. Yeah, personas is fine. Makes sense. Right.
Speaker 3: Yeah, I guess for a word post, you have your admin. Correct. Or like your super user, and then you have your, we don't have the words for this yet, because we don't have it currently. Yeah. I would say maybe admin and user being the two designators. And that would be for the...
Speaker 4: That would be for both. That would be for all of them. Because Jordan and I and Steve, we're going to be the admin, internal admin.
Steve Muniak: But those are roles within, those are roles within...
Speaker 4: We don't fit in any of those.
Steve Muniak: Yeah, there's a management role. Mm-hmm.
Speaker 4: Okay, so that makes sense.
Speaker 3: It would be in the persona.
Steve Muniak: What's that.
Speaker 3: It would be under the persona, right.
Steve Muniak: Yes, there's a management persona, internal management persona. So I'm gonna add an external management persona.
Jake Herwaldt: Yeah.
Speaker 3: Okay, so is that five and six.
Jake Herwaldt: That's like five and six. Okay. Because they're essentially, they own the hierarchy then. Yeah. Because that's like an external vendor would be like the person who's doing.
Speaker 3: I'm looking at external vendor, all parts.
Jake Herwaldt: Right.
Speaker 3: And then under all parts, you have whoever is administrating the account and then you have users. So it feels like those are sub-items that go under the ring. Yeah, that's fine. Okay, so I'm gonna call it admin user. Yeah, we can even name that. That's the two different levels, correct? Yeah. Is that for all of them? Yes.
Speaker 8: Okay, so yes.
Speaker 3: What if you call out a field service, different than for a buyer? That's where you could argue it would still be an SWP buyer, but it would be a completely different profile. I think it should be a different persona. I would actually like that with a five. Like, number of questions.
Speaker 4: Well, external buyer users? Are we going to split users.
Speaker 3: We could do that as a profile type under, yeah. Like, there's the procurement team, but then there's a field service engineer. And I feel like a procurement user, is going to have different work than a field service engineer. Absolutely. Yeah. So I would agree. I would think that admin user should this be external buyer. Oh, sorry. So admin, should it be FSC and then procurement? Yeah.
Speaker 8: like FSE and internally we would have the same, right.
Speaker 4: Would we set that up for our FSE.
Steve Muniak: On the buy side, yeah.
Speaker 8: Maybe like the event is the copy of the FSE.
Speaker 4: There's not like an overall system or portal management like up there right now.
Steve Muniak: But it's part of the administrative function, I think.
Speaker 4: But it wouldn't fit under vendor or buyer.
Speaker 3: Yeah, because we're saying block imaging is just another customer. We need to talk about pitting that as like an ad.
Jake Herwaldt: Mm-hmm. Yeah. What would you call that? You'd call that like a platform admin? Yeah.
Steve Muniak: That's exactly right.
Speaker 3: Would you park Biomed out differently, or have that live under external buyers and external lenders? Because that would also be completely different profile type. And, though, just throwing this in there, too, you would have buyers that would need to do both DI and Biomed. It would be very different. I would say Biomed.
Speaker 3: Every single one of them. OK.
Jake Herwaldt: So then once we have these, and I'm not saying we're done, but once we have these fully defined now, then we would double click into one of them. And then now Spiderweb out to say, okay, what are all the... And then we'll get to what's in scope, out of scope, but essentially what are they doing within the platform, outside the platform. Do we feel like this is the list.
Speaker 4: I think so. For our first take, is it the list.
Jake Herwaldt: Yeah, yeah, yeah. Now of this, which of all of us that are in the room, who's all going to be in the room tomorrow, Steve.
Steve Muniak: Tomorrow is going to be the five people.
Jake Herwaldt: Okay, good. So who should we focus on of this list today with our... How much time do we have? Three hours. We'll hopefully get through several of these.
Speaker 4: I'd love external buyer. Okay. I think that's going to be the biggest one that tomorrow they're as focused on.
Jake Herwaldt: Right. Okay, great. So I have what our first shot at trying to define this, which again is not meant to be us actually... getting this correct, but just as a starting point. So now what we're going to want to do, invert this to sticky notes, confirm, mark this up, do whatever you want. But yeah, we'll probably slap .
Speaker 1: Here's the rule I want to impose. I want to give you guys a few minutes to look this over. And you can use a marker, you can use a pen, you can do whatever you want. But find something wrong. You can't find something wrong with it. Find the thing that elicits the most emotional response, whether it's joy, because it's such a wonderful thing, or it's frustration, because it's.
Speaker 1: something that's not wonderful. Then make a note, and then. Or if it's wrong, obviously, make a note. We're going to want to repair it and fix it going forward. I've never felt so old in my life. Jake said that all of you guys would have no problem making this, because he doesn't have a problem making this. I'm just teasing. He asked me, is this OK? I don't know. But here's the rule that I would like to impose on you guys.
Speaker 1: I would like you to always have at least two post-it notes in front of you that have something on it, either something that you're going to eventually add. Either it's going to be a point of frustration, or it's going to be an idea that you have, or it's going to be some piece of information, so that when we get to the thing where your note applies to you, you're ready to put it up there. Here's why. Because once we get into a rhythm of this, you might question whether or not.
Speaker 1: What was that thing I thought of? So if you always have two, if that's the rule, to always have two up there, you're kind of always ready to bring that up. And it's also just a good practice. I might get three or four things up there when you look at it. And it gets us in the habit of everybody, participating in building this out. Probably going to put another two out there, because that might not wrap it all the way across. Ideas? It could be ideas. It could be corrections to this. It could be, I have a story to tell about this thing.
Speaker 1: because it's not right. This is going to need more information. Please use the Sharpies on the post-it notes. You can use whatever you want on your diaries. Does that make sense? Any questions about that.
Jake Herwaldt: So we will continue. I'm sure we'll continue to fight the idea of we want to focus on current state, but also focus on future at the same time. And so, yeah, just keep both of those in mind.
Speaker 3: can you tell me the difference visually in like the top row is a bunch of red arrows except for creating a recognition what was the designator basically the.
Jake Herwaldt: idea is with creating a new rec you're actually doing that thing the rest are just kind of screens they kind of see information on so yes we'll want to.
Speaker 8: define those but the complexity I would assume you said you were gonna be done.
Speaker 1: We're really just biding our time.
Steve Muniak: Can you say, let's say, within my capabilities, what does that mean? Can you call out where? Decision box after pool SRC view within my capabilities.
Speaker 4: Is that what you mean.
Jake Herwaldt: Am I on the right one? Oh, no. Zoom back out. It's under vendor. Sorry.
Speaker 8: There we go.
Speaker 4: So your homework that you assigned to us last week, can we incorporate some of that into this.
Speaker 1: What was the homework that I assigned.
Speaker 4: It was like five questions. You said if we wrote it down, we'd get extra points.
Speaker 1: Oh, yeah. Did you write it down? Oh.
Speaker 4: Nice.
Speaker 1: So this is my race. This is my brilliant plan. We want to do extra credit, though. Right. You said we'd get a thing. This is so, I always hope for 100% participation, and yet I realize that I don't want to shame people who didn't participate. Oh, okay. Who are saying, I see. Judge me. Yes, this is exactly where those things are. This is the same philosophy, which is take some time,
Speaker 1: look it over, write things down. When we get in the flow of the conversation, it is meant to either accelerate us, because we get to a point where we're like, rather than stop it because somebody else has an idea. Or it's meant to get us distracted on a new thing to make sure we didn't lose it. There's a handful of reasons why getting it written down and getting it on the board preps us. But your sheet should be full of basically these sticking.
Steve Muniak: Check with these guys, we have room till 5.
Speaker 4: I'm like, I've reached my limitation, gang.
Speaker 7: I'm like, I can't ask, let me go somewhere else. All the awesomeness.
Speaker 1: I don't want to necessarily force you guys to read through until you map out every single thing. I don't mind us going through. But I just wanted to make sure you guys have time to have some thoughts, have some interruptions. Again, this was, actually, Jake, do you want to go through, just give us a brief how you built up this workflow so that they know what they're competing against.
Jake Herwaldt: JAKE ARCHIBALD O' Yeah, essentially, this is taking a compilation of everything that we got from the RFP, from the videos that we got sent, from trying to think of where it ended. It didn't take into any consideration anything that we talked about last Wednesday. But basically, from there, trying to create a web of what is the flow based, on all of those materials. And so, again, there could be clear gaps in this. There could be just ways. oversimplifying of things and then this is this is meant to be current states.
Jake Herwaldt: and then so this is not ideating at all but that doesn't mean we can't talk.
Speaker 3: about it so this would be like when you go to the version you have now that's.
Speaker 1: right now right but we can have that can totally be yeah we do need to be sticky note it can be figure me something here we'll just start don't not think about it don't think about us because that's gonna be part of the everything we do in terms of categorizing things and saying oh this is a direct extension we'll want to make sure when we're building this we're keeping this in mind so do not but.
Jake Herwaldt: Steve and team let's keep in mind obviously we only have three hours not even anymore of these workflows which ones would we like to get through if we get through fewer that's fine that gives us more time to like to find future state but I don't want to, If you get stuck on one, if you guys are like, oh, shoot, based on who's in the room today, we should probably get through four of the five. Or if we only need to get two of the five through today based on who we have, like, then let's take our time.
Steve Muniak: So tomorrow morning we've got the self-divide. We'll have to get them up to speed a little bit on some of these. Okay. And then I know Vicki's here tomorrow after. Allie, what's your available tomorrow.
Speaker 2: I'm available tomorrow. I believe it's three today. I will also be here in the morning. I'm available all day.
Jake Herwaldt: We'll be here in the morning as well. So of those items, which is best.
Speaker 3: I think external buyer still because the procurement team would be internal buyer.
Jake Herwaldt: Great. So external buyer.
Speaker 3: Would be the number one. And then I would say external vendor for number two, wouldn't you think.
Steve Muniak: For today.
Speaker 3: If you're both today, that would be.
Steve Muniak: Let me set the stage a little bit, too, for internal buyers before we go too far down here. Yeah. Internal buyers, the only screen they're working out of is in Salesforce 3. So it's, you know, the internal buyers and internal vendor are all working in 360. So Allie's team is only working in 360. That's all they do when they're selling a product or sourcing a product.
Steve Muniak: The internal buyer is only working in 360. They see nothing else. And I've been trying, noodling in my notebook, trying to give you guys a better diagram of what systems they reside in. Great.
Speaker 1: Is that visible enough? No. No? Not at all yet. All right. I hate it, too. I'm glad you guys spoke up. I was testing you. It's an internal buyer, so I'm thinking of it. the right thing based on the video you put out. Is this any of this auto sourcing kind of flow? Is this internal.
Speaker 3: Everything, hey, everything's auto sourced.
Speaker 1: So it's currently in Salesforce. Are you guys also thinking that it would stay in Salesforce going forward, or are we gonna move some of this to, are we thinking about moving some of this to the new stuff? I assume you're moving some of this, that's the kind of ask.
Steve Muniak: And it's my question for Sam. I know. As you have described this project internally as it started happening, what kind of changes to 360 or the 360 two.
Speaker 3: In a perfect world, and I could be like massively, oversimplifying this, so you'll have to tell me. If you think about what we're trying to build as a package that could be our stock as its own business, I just see, I feel like the flow behind sourcing has to, or I'll take this.
Jake Herwaldt: Even for an internal person.
Speaker 3: Absolutely. Because what we're saying is we can manage this for you, customer, from a vendor perspective, or from a customer perspective, but the logic all lives here in the.
Steve Muniak: So, again, if I'm Andy Jarvis, he's a guy, are you saying that Andy would then be using a web interface, or Andy would know that he's using a web interface? That. He would not know.
Speaker 3: Yep. So he would be in his flow. He wouldn't even know he's using a web interface. The web interface is giving him access to how it's sourcing, whether it's like the tiered vendors. It did do the vendor management when it comes to sourcing, not like the human vendor management.
Steve Muniak: Yes.
Speaker 3: It's very different.
Steve Muniak: Yeah. This is some stuff we're going to have to really dig into, because there's a lot of complexity within the roles of that internal buyer.
Speaker 4: Yeah, that'll be a good conversation. Especially on the FSE side. Yeah.
Speaker 1: They could use some better structure and simplicity, at the same time.
Speaker 3: And that's why, if you bring that in, as its own profile, and give them access to it, we might have to build it differently. But it would be awesome to have that.
Jake Herwaldt: Who you're hoping, I guess.
Speaker 1: I want to, I think this could just, take a second and help us be more visually organized. When an external buyer signs on to the org, switches tabs to this thing. What are the three phrases they're saying? So I'm going to put words in your mouth, because I just want to get these out, because I think they're going to be the starters for when we go. Because we know it's all one workflow of it. I need a part, and I have to get something to do with it.
Speaker 1: But the first phrase is, I need a part. That is the first phrase somebody says in their brain, and they go there. And then the second one is, I need to check on responses. Yeah, right? I need to, like, I made my, like, let's, let's, there's these different, like, I need to go back.
Speaker 3: The second thing would be, like, I have a lot of options here.
Speaker 1: Oh, yeah, yeah, options, I have options here. I need to choose which vendor. Yeah, yeah, thank you. I need to choose a vendor. And then the next one would be. I need to submit my order.